line sire-marin magistrate et membre de
la ligue des droits de l'homme bonsoir
et vénissian mara merci de répondre à
nos questions en direct sur arte france
à quoi est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre
d'ici demain selon vous au palais
bourbon beaucoup annoncent des débats
musclés au sein de l'hémicycle
oui bien sûr il ya le problème de la
réforme savait que l' ordonnance de 1945
sur les mineurs avaient déjà été réformé
39 fois donc là on passe à un code pénal
de façon plus cohérente dans l'hémicycle
ce à quoi il faut s'attendre c'est un
débat effectivement sur le fait de
scinder en deux d'abord la culpabilité
dans les trois mois où des faits dès la
cambre été commis et ensuite six à neuf
mois après on passera à la sanction
ça serait une bonne chose pour
l'essentiel des professionnels c'est pas
tellement le problème le problème pour
les professionnels et les 500 juge des
enfants de france
si vous voulez c'est l'état des
tribunaux pour enfants
c'est à dire que il ya énormément de
procédure en stock on demande le
ministre demande aux tribunaux pour
enfants en ce moment de déstocker on est
presque dans un black friday la de la
justice des mineurs
c'est à dire demande d'enlever un tiers
des procédures pénales pour renvoyer au
parquet pour faire des mesures
alternatives et c'est ça le problème en
fait c'est la question des moyens
en réalité le fait de scinder en deux la
culpabilité d'abord puis de prononcer
une mesure d'investigation pour être
plus informés sur la sanction a prononcé
ce qui permettra par exemple de demander
aux mineurs de réparer le dommage qu'il
a causé à la victime
ça c'est plutôt une assez bonne chose
pour ensuite prononcé une peine adaptée
ce qui pose problème dans cette future
dans ce futur code pénal des mineurs
c'est plutôt que pour certains mineurs y
aura une sorte de comparution immédiate
qui ne dit pas son nom mais qui sera en
réalité le fait de les juger
immédiatement sa ces instruments
justement beaucoup d'observateurs ou
d'opposants tous les cas évoque le côté
répressif du texte et à linverse eric
dupond moretti lui
par le site d'une réforme historique
pour mieux protéger les mineurs qui
croire c'est pas vraiment une réforme
historique les principes essentiels de
la justice des mineurs demain un juge
spécialisé pour les moins de 18 ans le
fait également que l'éducatif prime sur
le répressif et ce sera une possibilité
pour le juge des enfants d'être mieux
informés sur la peine à prononcer la
question c'est que actuellement un juge
des enfants qui prononce une mesure
d'assistance éducative c'est à dire pour
les mineurs en danger puisque vous savez
que le juge des enfants a deux
casquettes les mineurs délinquants et
les mineurs en danger qui pour protéger
les services éducatifs met à peu près 18
mois pour commencer à exercer cette
mesure c'est ça le problème essentiel et
les principes essentiels la justice des
mineurs vont être conservées mais y'a
aucun principe valable s'il n'y a pas de
moyens pour les mettre en oeuvre
qu'est ce que ça veut dire le à un
mineur comme à l'heure actuelle qui
commet une infraction mettant à 16 ans
et demi ou 17 ans et qui est jugée à 19
ans c'est ça le problème essentiel qui
se posent en france pour la justice des
mineurs
on est jugé comme majeur alors qu'on a
commis un acte de délinquance comme mina
ça ne veut plus rien dire ça n'a aucun
sens et partage le biais d'actions est
ce que vous pensez que la justice pour
mineurs peut être améliorée alors alors
la justice des mineurs elle peut être
améliorée si véritablement on renforce
le nombre de juges des enfants et on
décide que les services éducatifs vont
être considérablement en forme renforcer
en nombre d'éducateurs
il faut le premier le premier aspect
important la justice des mineurs c'est
que si vous voulez
l'intervention du juge des enfants
arrivent très peu de temps après que les
actes délinquants a été commis parce que
un mineur n'a pas le même sens non plus
du déroulement du temps qu'un majeur est
si injuste qu'on n'arrive pas tout de
suite après l'acte délinquant si vous
voulez deux ans après ça ne veut plus
rien dire
le temps d'un mineur il est beaucoup
plus immédiats que celui d'un majeur
donc c'est ça la réforme essentielle à
feurs c'est de faire en sorte que les
mesures prononcées par un juge des
enfants soient appliquées de façon la
plus rapide possible
merci une liste où les annales merci
sève une cire marrant d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
magistrate et membre de la ligue des
droits de l'homme